mission Oh badass did identity but [ __ ]
ah ah
Brad what do you do Brent I'm Rick Hey
oh I kill him for you Brad what am i
doing buck was say no juices that's a
laughing a better they go this is
ridiculous get Mississippi's
Felipe's temper back to Canada you
hippies [ __ ] hippies everywhere I got
Oh way back I don't have any more bombs
now wait I did I put Jam for the bomb
breath again breath the boiler again
okay go back Nancy's go bless you Canada
why are they old from Canada I'm back
brac cut whoa
bright I see did you try shanked him
okay okay okay okay okay
missiles are the Frog hey what is
happening this is the Balkans
uh oh [ __ ] oh thanks Brad that was too
close Brent yeah get back we did it I'm
just gonna keep saying brah like less
yeah bruh
what's wrong Deborah so dark I don't
still sick I got bigger names in I mean
my end
what yeah camel power I want it too Oh
guys and squares jelly squares my frame
rate for a mate is like [ __ ] 200k
getting that one please
yeah brought up is that baby is dead
[ __ ]
I don't even know what's going on I'm so
it loses better than cocaine man
have you tried cocaine oh my god no no
no no the Braavos brother yeah blah blah
Toby once you get here
how's it going audio audience
oh yeah audience audience hippies did it
hey thanks hey where's my movie yeah so
I got the camel oh yeah go you're free
hippie they like to pull the short sale
by users because shoot that thing but it
look like
I'm not camel don't drink out cami Q
okay check him check up wait wait oh
you'll be a shank [ __ ] oh hey yo what
is this ah hello the hippies walking
hello yeah [ __ ] hey dude like so sharing
I don't know it's um a me hey I'm so
gangster look at me shoot yeah how would
it be your mummy hey you can't be a
mummy
it gives me stuff my god mommy Oh mommy
I stab I shoot ducks yes
[ __ ] yes the nickname ass
take that duck funky dogs your looks
your memory because oh no GAD a me they
got me and at the phone ah I gotta do
these flips yeah all right I like this
poor guy is this a hobo okay I'm
shooting see shoot him oh damn those
clothes
what an [ __ ] shot him Hey Oh what the
hell
flame though there's a bomb Oh again oh
just do it that ass spankin
smack it oh yeah you like that
alright jump on him oh no I'll shoot it
ass monkey okey oh so much going on hey
watch out you can not my shot is okay
can't believe he drops the [ __ ] I'm glad
you're so worried about me though well
I'm just trying to do no zombie hahaha
damn it I like your eyes they're so
bright
Thanks I still got my sun shades on away
over here eh oh we did it
yeah oh oh [ __ ] rap I got it
I got no dougie damn it was a trap
avenge me what's a kill this dog was
this just lad I'm just gonna gently
dainty look at it did did it II was in
the mood for 20 legs
this is swinging oh ma don't worry my
friend
Oh what are you doing Brad shoot down ah
ah there we go
oh god he's shooting stuff as well yeah
he got me you're like ah yeah alright oh
god Jay says don't worry about Brad yeah
we did oh look at my face
yeah i'm joe god oh god I miss your
closure bro my nipples just pierced
yours yes will my bits always and
forever
okay one more
okay oh no it's in the toilet now you
still shoot in the man in the toilet
wow that's not even a toilet right damn
it a shot guard it's a trap it's a trap
what I'm about a space
dammit I'm an [ __ ] who you are at a
breath because you hold down America Oh
Oprah oh god I could flew like a [ __ ]
kill the kid pigs piggies Terry I'm so
fat now bruh yummy eating the pigs with
their many things that barbecue L Ohio
wash planes rocket launcher what the
hell is going on did it what's this I'm
scared about this it's 96 oh there's got
eggs oh [ __ ]
watch out one of the tags doing this
music it's like some elevator music the
whole time and like Jeff said let me
dude
really yeah oh so many coins whoa boys
what is coins have to do with it
no no like all the sudden coins you just
get the Dean ah oh yes what oh yeah
America land of the free
Oh No else how'd he get out [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
eject eject it's gonna blow I saw
already beat him now
Oh God there we go do it
yeah more than more than four warden
hormone and
got make for freedom no prisoner I guess
like hey hey guys cry here like this
video if you enjoyed
suck my ass brofist